hello everyone the six-game match
between Vasiliev on chicken way he just
finished and it was a very exciting
event it was played in Netherlands in
who given I couldn't really find any
latest information on the match because
they don't really update their page like
in real time but nevertheless vastly one
took managed to win this one after his
bold King Marchan round three games four
and five were drawn and the way he
managed to retaliate in round six so
they had to play they had to go into
tiebreaks they played two games two
10-minute games a magic one in Game one
it was a pretty clean victory with the
white pieces and in Game two where he
tried to try to mix it up when he had
the white pieces but in the end it cost
him a piece and also the game pretty
classic classic clash of youth versus
experience so let's see this game way he
plays
efore and we have d5 for those of you
who enjoy the Scandinavian defense this
game can also be quite instructive he
capture Sun d5 and Queen captures on d5
Knight to c3 developing a piece with an
attack on the Queen Queen to a5 and now
d4 event replace c6 restricting the
movement of this night and also
preparing an escape route for the Queen
and c7 Bishop to b2 now Bishop to a5
Bishop to c4 by awayyyy
it's better to develop a piece this
Knight doesn't really have any good
discoveries the Queen can always just go
to c7 e six now Queen to f3
Queen to e2 is also possible but
probably ye has something prepared for
for blitz games or any rapid games
Knight to d7 where you castles Queen
side and Knight G to f6 Knight G to E -
quinta c7 we have h3 restricting the
movement of the night also not allowing
any Bishop to g4 ideas so this knife can
now freely move h6 we have rook H to e1
and eventual castles also Queen side
King to b1 we have Bishop to d6 and
for attacking the bishop on a5 Bishop
goes to to h7 and well this is well not
the critical position of the game but an
interesting position eventually has this
immensely strong bishop on h7 it's
slicing all the way here to see - and
x-raying the f king and b1 so this is
something that really as white you don't
want black to have so probably the best
move here is Bishop to d3 simply offer
an exchange of bishops and black will
probably have to accept this there
really is no better move but instead
after this Bishop - 8 7 way he played
Knight to f4 probably with the idea well
if Bishop to d3 and Bishop captures on
d3 the position would be pretty equal so
what way he was probably going for here
is Bishop to d3 next and after Bishop
captures then the knight will recapture
and d3 so the knight can maybe go to c5
in the future or wherever but this allow
divine choke to push a 5 with a temple
on the night and well now now Knight the
d3 doesn't really achieve anything you
lose this pawn on d4 as it is undefended
so D captures on e4 d captors only 5 by
wayy Knight captures and now
Avantika is attacking the Queen and f3
and also the bishop on c4 Queen to e2
was played and well Avant Chuck would
definitely enjoy capturing this bishop
on c4 as he does have a double attack on
this night on f4 after his own Knight
moves
but after Queen recaptures and c4 the
Queen will also be defending the knight
as well as the bishop on d2 so if I'd
replace rook H to e8 now now that rook
is eyeing the Queen on e2 and here
Bishop to e3 was played and with this
move way he completely throws the game
as this Knight is attacked twice with
the bishop and the Queen after this
Knight moves probably something like
night the g2 had to be played or maybe
maybe night to h5 one of those moves
definitely but not the one way he chose
Bishop to e3 this allows you bunch of
in the game immediately and he does it
with knife captures on c4 well you do
have to recapture Queen captures on c4
and the Queen is protecting the knight
on f4 as well as the bishop but this is
easily easily fixed event took place b5
and what in this position way you resign
the game as he is losing the piece the
Queen has to move even if the Queen
moves to a square like d4 at the try and
still protect this night and f4 c5 is
coming and now there is no more room for
a queen to defend the knight white could
play a move like Knight capture some b5
to attack von cooks queen but seek a
person before and the game is over
Knight captures Bishop captures and the
problem is we can't even recapture this
pawn because his knight is hanging on f4
so we saw this he didn't want to
continue and after b5 he resigned the
game so after six classical games the
result was three two three four games
were drawing a bunch of one game three
away he won Game six and even took one
to two rapid games in a row thus winning
the match and well we all know rapid and
blitz is no problem for a von Schuch
after that 2016 World blitzen world
blitz and rapid championship in Qatar
Doha where he defeated world champion
Magnus Carlsen both in blitz and in
rapid so yeah that's the game and that's
it for eventual games for now as of
tomorrow I'm doing the David Brownstein
book the great Zurich tournament of 1953
and those videos will be a bit more
educational I hope you don't mind that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can share to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon